was ich bin also eigentlich vom
charakter genauso wie beyoncé oder vin
diesel
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video gestrigen video habe ich ja einen
test gemacht ob ich vielleicht ein guter
vater wäre zu 40 prozent sind sie du
wärst die perfekte mutter
ja und da kam ein
raus dass ich eine gute mutter sein
würde also nichts worauf man irgendwie
stolz sein könnte aber unter meinem
gestrigen video wurde mir ein
persönlichkeitstest zugeschickt und da
steht schon unsere leser sagen dass der
sixteen personale tiefst es so genau ist
dass es fast ein bisschen unheimlich ist
wow trikot er halte eine genaue
beschreibung davon wer du bist und warum
du dinge auf die art und weise angeht
wie du es tust das ist natürlich super
cool turbo kostenloser
persönlichkeitstest neresheim explorer
da sollte es weniger als zwölf minuten
dafür brauchen beantworte die fragen
ehrlich auch werde die antworten nicht
gefallen versuche keine neutralen
antworten zu hinterlassen alles klar
der test besteht angeblich so aus 60
fragen so das video könnte länger werden
das ganze hier ist kein placement oder
keine kooperation mit dieser website
aber ich habe trotz meiner testen die
beschreibung gepackt einfach nur damit
ihr das nebenbei auch mal machen könnt
und selber herausfinden können was eure
persönlichkeit ist es fällt ihnen schwer
sich anderen menschen vorzustellen ich
würde sagen ich hab kein problem damit
es wegen mache ich einfach mal so
zweitens stimmt sie verlieren sich oft
so sehr in gedanken dass sie ihr umfeld
ignorieren oder vergessen definitiv ich
habe das so häufig sie versuchen ihre e
mails möglichst schnell zu beantworten
und mögen keine unfreundliche inbox auf
keinen fall ich mache das immer so gut
es geht und habe alles immer sauber in
my mail ordner das fällt ihnen leicht
entspannt und konzentriert zu bleiben
setzt wenn sie unter druck stehen
normalerweise beginnen sie keine
gespräche doch ich bin wirklich ein sehr
gesprächige typ und die nächste frage
sie tun selten etwas nur aus neugierde
wo ich würde das ganze mal auf neutral
packen weil ich dazu grad echt keine
antwort weiß wir sind jetzt auch schon
auf der zweiten seite des tests
angekommen also hier oben steht jetzt
wir haben zehn geschafft das heißt jeder
weiteren sechs fragen sechs mal zehn
sind 60 wie ich bereits gesagt habe 60
fragen sie fühlen sich anderen überlegen
[Musik]
kann ich nicht einschätzen hätte von mir
sagen dass bestimmt irgendwie joker der
ist voll arrogant vollends ist aber ich
weiß nicht ich kann das selber nicht
einschätzen irgendwie ich weiß nicht ich
kann jetzt nicht stimmt nicht sagen dann
versteht was ich meine ich glaube ich
mal einfach neutrale organisation ist
ihnen wichtiger als anpassungsvermögen
jetzt ist mir auf jeden fall ein
bisschen wichtiger
sie sind normalerweise hoch motiviert
und haben viel energie es ist ihnen
wichtiger dass niemand verärgert wird
als dass sie eine debatte gewinnen nein
ich würde sagen so ein bisschen ein also
lieber das dass sich leute mit meiner
meinung verärgere als dass ich meine
meinung aufgebe und mich irgendwie mann
passen
hört sich so an als wäre ich das größte
ignorante arsch der welt
ich werde gerade angerufen
sie haben oft das gefühl dass sie sich
bei anderen rechtfertigen müssen ja eh
definitiv richtig häufig ich weiß nicht
ob ich die frage richtig verstehe aber
wenn es darum geht wenn wir leute
schreiben so yao luca wir wollen uns von
zehn minuten treffen ich habe immer das
gefühl zu sagen hey yo ich hatte noch
dies zu tun das zu tun versteht das
bitte und so ich rechtfertige mich immer
für alles in meinem leben ihr umfeld zu
hause und am arbeitsplatz ist recht
ordentlich stimmt schaut euch mal mein
arbeitsplatz an hier sitze ich da ist
mein handy eine wasserflasche und eine
tüte also vielmehr liegt hier einfach
wirklich nicht rum es macht ihnen nichts
aus im mittelpunkt zu stehen
ich würde sagen stimmt er nicht also ich
bin jetzt eigentlich nicht der mensch
der unbedingt irgendwo auf einer bühne
stehen muss und irgendwie das alles nur
sich um ihn dreht das mach ich dann
lieber mit leuten zusammen oder so also
ich könnte auch nie eine show machen wo
ich irgendwie alleine irgendwas mache
außerhalb hier vor meinem pc und der
kamera hier heute merchandise kaufen
also das feld kann eigentlich nur von
jobs leben weil aber wo ich jetzt
erzählen bin ich möchte euch nur kurz
sagen dass die rub zuvor wie das smiley
moody's in meinem shop bestellen können
die kommen auf save vor weihnachten an
allerdings bei den anderen artikeln also
bei den pizza pudding pizza shirts und
den track smileys wetter die sind
vorbestellbar wieder allerdings hans
sein dass die nicht vor weihnachten
ankommen wir waren einfach zu krass beim
launch und die popsongs und allgemein
schon komplett ausverkauft ihr seid
einfach zu krass leute also die smileys
könnt ihr safe wieder bestellen die
kombos vor weihnachten an allerdings bei
dem cracks mediziner und bei den alexa
sachen ist nur eine geringfügige chance
das wirklich vor weihnachten ankommt
aber man jetzt weiter mit dem test ihrer
meinung nach sind sie mehr praktisch
veranlagt als kreativ ich würde das
ganze als neutral beurteilen
andere schaffen es selten sie zu
verärgern stimmt nicht ihre reisepläne
sind für gewöhnlich gut überlegt auf
jeden fall ich hab keinen bock spontane
sache die finde es oft schwierig die
gefühle anderer zu verstehen er nicht so
also ich glaube ich verstehe es nicht
ganz gut und ihre laune kann sich sehr
schnell ändern ja ich bin so ein mensch
ich kann sagen ihr wholesale ich bin ein
neues video im hammer geil ich hatte
mein leben bei einer diskussion sollte
die wahrheit wichtiger sein als die
wunden punkte anderer ich würde so ein
bisschen zu stimmen weil oft ist die
wahrheit halt einfach nicht schön für
manche leute
sie machen sich selbst sorgen darüber
wie sich ihre handlungen auf andere
auswirken ja auf jeden fall dieser
arbeitsweise ähnelt eher willkürlichen
energie schüben als eine methodischen
organisation organisierten ansatz ist
will ich nicht sagen sie sind oft
gegenüber anderen neidisch
eigentlich finde ich wirklich nie
neidisch also ich bin eigentlich ein
mensch der mit dem zufrieden ist was er
hat also ich lebe jetzt keinen enormen
krassen luxus lifestyle wie
amerikanische youtuber mit jets und
lamborghinis und alles sondern bin halt
einfach so zum spaß
deswegen will ich das ganze als neutral
beurteilen einfach ein interessantes
buch oder ein videospiel es oftmals
besser als eine gesellschaftliche
veranstaltung auf jeden fall einen plan
entwickeln zu können und diesen zu
verfolgen ist der wichtigste teil eines
jeden projekts würde ich auch definitiv
zu stimmen die lassen sich selten von
fantasien und ideen ablenken doch
relativ häufig und auch von vögeln die
einfach draußen herum fliegen oder vom
wetter wenn jemand nicht schnell auf
ihre e mail antwortet machen sie sich
sorgen ob sie etwas falsches gesagt
haben was für e mail
ich verstehe eigentlich fast nie e mails
als elternteil ist es ihnen wichtig dass
sich hin zu einem liebenswürdigen
menschen heranwächst als unbedingt
intelligent zu sein
ich würde sagen stimmt total so ein
bisschen so teilt natürlich sollte mein
kind unbedingt liebenswürdig sein und
total nett und was weiß ich aber so ein
komplett hohl dummes kind ist natürlich
auch nicht gut
sie lassen nicht zu dass andere
handlungen beeinflussen
da stimmt eigentlich immer was möchte
ihre träume drehen sich häufig um die
reale werden deren ereignisse auf jeden
fall ich träume nie von irgendwas fix
schnell oder irgendwas keine ahnung an
einem neuen arbeitsplatz machen sie
schnell bei gesellschaftlichen
aktivitäten mit das ist mein essen ist
die heiß ich beantworte die frage
einfach mal mit neutral sehen pro
visieren eher als dass sie vorsichtig
planen stimmt nicht improvisieren die
echt selten
emotionen steuern sie mehr als dass
diese sie diese steuern
nein ich werde nie eigentlich nie aus
emotionen zu ähnlichen handlungen
geführt sie gehen gern zur
gesellschaftlichen veranstaltungen bei
denen man sich verkleidet oder
rollenspiele stattfinden also ich würde
mal sagen ja ich gehe zumindest sehr
gerne ins kino und das ist ja auch so
eine form von gesellschaftlicher
veranstaltung mit rollenspielen und sie
verbringen häufig zeit damit
unrealistisch und praktische ideen zu
überdenken die jedoch faszinierend sind
nein wenn es nicht geschehen kann
braucht man darüber ja nicht nachdenken
leute die nächsten fragen mache ich
jetzt einfach mal mit musik im
hintergrund und beantwortet die einfach
mal im schnelldurchlauf
[Musik]
okay leute meinen test ist jetzt fertig
nachdem ich jetzt in den letzten 34
minuten noch die letzten fragen
beantwortet habe und das was dabei
herausgekommen ist ist dein
persönlichkeitstyp ist verteidiger i sft
kann man das noch eine auswertung mein
verstand ist eher introvertiert was das
hätte ich nie gedacht meine energie ist
realistisch dass es auf jeden fall klar
das hätte ich mir auch selber so
eigentlich vorher schon sagen können
meine natur ist prinzipien fokussiert
und logik fokussiert so ein bisschen der
mitte hätte ich jetzt auch so eingestuft
meine taktiken sind 92 prozent planen 08
suchen das ist definitiv so ich habe für
jeden scheiß einen plan ich habe einen
ablaufplan was ich auf youtube hochladen
auf meinem handy sind überall meine
termine meine studien gruppensitzungen
meine veranstaltungen der uni alles
mögliche eingetragen mail ordner alles
sortiert also ich bin echt übel
sortierter mensch das soll jetzt nicht
heißen von wegen jo ich bin voll
abgehoben und sagt euch hier dass sich
der perfekteste organisierte mensch der
welt wind sondern ich sehe das ganze
eher negativ achten also dadurch dass
ich alles immer so planen und alles
komplett konkret habe ich gar keinen
zeiten gar keine zeit mehr
beziehungsweise gar keine gar keinen
platz mehr dafür ding was spontan zu
machen versteht irgendwie was ich meine
und meine identität ist er vorsichtig
als durchsetzungsfähig das ist krass das
hätte ich so nicht gedacht der iss j
persönlichkeitstyp ist einzigartig da
viele ihrer qualitäten sich der
definition ihrer einzelnen
charaktereigenschaften den ziehen obwohl
sie die prinzipien fokussierte f
charaktereigenschaft besitzen haben die
ssj exzellente analytische fähigkeiten
um alte was andere erst fj vin diesel
queen elizabeth was ich bin also
eigentlich vom charakter genauso wie
beyoncé oder vin diesel
da hast was ihr vom video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe euch hat dieser
test gefallen wenn etwas getan hat las
man like da für mich war es einfach mega
spannend zu sehen was ich für ein typ
bin wie gesagt habe ich euch den
persönlichkeitstest einfach machen in
der beschreibung verlinkt die könnte
einfach selber mal drauf gehen und ich
habe jetzt insgesamt in der overtime ok
ich hab' 30 minuten gebraucht aber das
schafft ihr wahrscheinlich schneller
hier findet ihr ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren und automatisch an einem
gewinnspiel teil wo ich derzeit eine
nintendo 3ds xl verlose also go ahead
and duett sweat kostenlos und hier
findet ihr ein gestriges video
eingeblendet
durch einen vaterschaftstest gemacht
habe als ob ich bereit für ein baby wäre
es auch sehr cool geworden